We were at war when I was press secretary. So things are also different. Um,
but let's say something was happening and it was a national security issue.
And somebody within the government suggested I say such and such
answer at the briefing. Well, when I did,
because I was a reporter by training is I would double check and
triple check. So I had my deputies and I would say, Gordon,
can you call the national security council?
See if this is what they say is going to call, um, DOD,
you call the CIA, let's meet back here in 20 minutes.
And if everybody has the same answer, I'll say it at the podium.
And if we don't, then I would go to the cheapest staff's office. And I'd say,
we got a problem here because everybody's not settled and we have to get this
right, because people's lives are on the line.
I liked it.
You said this thing about that you needed sort of this unforced break. Do you,
do you think a lot of people are suddenly feeling that like,
just the way life is and how fast everything seems to move and social media and
the 24 hour news cycle that you're well aware of that we suddenly got this
break. And of course it's not for a good reason, but that,
but basically if you're okay right now and you've got a roof over your head,
and hopefully you have a couple of bucks that there really is an incredible
opportunity to kind of look at your life and look at the world a little bit
differently.
Absolutely. If you read any, um,
anyone saying like, w what, what do you really want in your life?
Or what it's that people feel over busy?
I made a new year's resolution that when people said,
how are you doing this a couple of years ago that I would stop saying I'm so
busy because everybody is so busy.
Everybody is trying and striving and doing, nobody says, Oh, I'm fine,
totally kicked back. I get eight hours of sleep a night. Everything's good.
Everybody has stuff. So I stopped saying that a couple of years ago,
and that was a good sort of mental shift for me. Um, and I,
but I know it in myself. Um,
I have a very hard time saying no to opportunities that come my way.
Everything's amazing. Especially like in New York city, would you, you know,
would you speak at this event for this wonderful charity,
but what about for this veterans group? And I can be out,
we night every single night of the week,
and then trying to catch up on life on the weekends.
And what I've realized is that you've having to tap the brakes because we have
to all do our part in this pandemic. It's been,
it's been actually really good for me and I don't have,
I know that I can't hold on to this completely when all of us returned to
normal. Um,
but I would like to figure out a way that I could hold onto a little bit of it
because I, it is better for me a lot better.
Yeah.
Well, it's interesting. It's one of the why I like doing your show,
because even though you're doing informational stuff,
you're doing like the daily grind political stuff,
like there is this other feeling that I think you have that a lot of shows kind
of miss,
which is that there's something that's going on in the world at all times that
doesn't have to do with politics. Exactly. And I think for you guys,
one of the cool things for me over the last couple of years,
as I've gotten to know, I would say you, Greg, Gutfeld,
who's a good buddy of yours and Tucker Carlson specifically. It's like,
when we watch you guys,
there's something a little bit different about watching someone on cable news
than on the internet. Like, it's almost like, are these people actual humans?
And I think you've been able to now show that window like, Oh,
there's a human here. Here's the dog. We're real people that,
that actually has been nice during this.
You know, it's interesting. I give, um, Greg,
Gutfeld a ton of credit for actually bringing me along on that,
because we started the five in July of 2011.
And before that I'd been the press secretary and that's a pretty serious job.
And even though I was in the public eye, um,
I didn't do a ton of personal things. Like, well,
we didn't have Instagram or Twitter then. So I,
I didn't really share my life because I thought who would care? Well,
then we start doing the five and we would be asked,
what do you think about this? And almost always,
I was instinctively giving the answer as if I was still the white house,
press secretary for George W. Bush. And at what point Greg said, no,
what do you think? And it was about drug legalization,
marijuana legalization. I've never smoked pot. I'm not into it.
I have a very unpopular opinion. I don't think it's a good idea,
but I realized I just froze.
And I had never given my personal opinion about anything out
loud.
And he pushed me a little and teased me a little and made it
okay for me to kind of just more be myself and not have to be the
press secretary so much anymore. Um,
and so I get asked an interview sometimes.
Is there something that people don't know about you like, Nope,
it's been 10 years. We've been doing the five and I was on red eyes.
There is pretty much nothing that people don't know about me.
So Greg actually really helped with that. And then especially on the five,
we take our S we take the new seriously,
but we don't take ourselves that seriously.
And life is life can be sweet and God meant for us
to be joyous. And I've really learned that from president George Bush to, um,
we worked very hard,
but we were always celebrating the joys of getting a chance to serve at
the highest levels of government for the best country the world's ever seen.
Yeah. So, all right. Let's back up to that for a second.
So for the people that don't know, you just referenced,
but you were press secretary for George W. Bush.
That means you're the person I remember watching you back in the day you were up
there, ants. Yeah. Yeah. You're answering, you're answering,
or at least to the best of the ability of a press,
secretary answering a lot of tough questions related to foreign policy and the
economy and all kinds of stuff. Um,
can you give me like some insight into what that job was like then versus
maybe how it is now? I mean, Trump barely has to use a secretary,
a press secretary, cause he was just kinda out there and,
and then the networks now, CNN doesn't even cover those things anymore. Uh,
you guys cover it, but how that sort of has changed over, you know,
it's been about what 20 years or so 15 years.
W it was interesting, um, in January of 2009,
so January 20th, 2009, uh, the bushes turned things over to the Obamas.
I was there for the last day. And then Peter, I left for Africa.
We went to South Africa for two weeks vacation in two weeks,
volunteering at a PEPFAR site. And I really,
I wanted that time to reset my priorities, reset my marriage,
reset my brain, and to get ready for this transition. But I think back on that,
and I didn't even have a Twitter account at that point.
And if you think just that, that was 2009, thinking 10 years,
how things changed so dramatically. Um,
and you think about the Obama campaign that absolutely smoked the Republicans on
social media in 2008 campaign.
And then in 2016,
president Trump realizes that he can talk directly to people.
And he was very comfortable with that. I don't know if George Bush ever would.
Sometimes I laugh and think about, um, writing a book of, um,
tweets, Bush would have sent by would have been
pretty funny, but I, um, it has changed so much.
Like now I will say this, I think for the country
briefings from the press secretary,
I always tried to turn down the temperature in the room. I thought,
why are we fighting? I'm here to give information.
You're here to elicit information. I always remembered too,
that those reporters have a job to do. And part of my job as press secretary,
I believe was protecting their right to have access to the government. And,
but here's the other thing.
I truly believe that a press briefing a daily press briefing
forces, a white house to have really good process,
because if they know that the press secretary is going to have to go out there
and she's going to have to answer answered these questions.
And that means you better call her back first,
if there's problems and the policy isn't settled,
everybody needs to get on the phone and get it done.
And another thing I used to do was let's say I was getting,
we were at war when I was press secretary. So things are also different. Um,
but let's say something was happening and it was a national security issue.
And somebody within the government suggested, I say such,
such answer at the briefing. Well, when I did,
because I was a reporter by training is I would double check and triple
check. So I had my deputies and I would say, Gordon,
can you call the national security council? See if this is what they say,
Tony's going to call, um, DOD, you call the CIA,
let's meet back here in 20 minutes. And if everybody has the same answer,
I'll say it at the podium. And if we don't,
then I would go to the cheapest staff's office. And I'd say,
we got a problem here because everybody's not settled and we have to get this
right, because people's lives are on the line. So in that case,
I feel like forcing good process is really good,
but everything's changed so much.
Who knows if it'll ever go back to being a daily press briefing,
not the president. Oh, he just finished.
He does some now I think he's starting to enjoy it in the briefing room.
Well, he's having a hell of a time in there clearly. I mean, I, it,
from the little bit that I can, you know,
I don't have time either to watch these huge things in their totality and their
totality, but when I watch them, I'm like, yeah, he's actually having fun.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.